brand strategy is why you are here grand
strategy are the larger objectives that
are important to you in your career to
your country to you personally students
at Yale have grand strategies these
relate of course what they wish to do in
life to their ambitions to navigating
the curriculum often for them falling in
love is a grand strategy and so we get
papers on how to do that or how to fall
out of love very slowly all of these
things in one way or another our grand
strategies grant really just means is it
important to you and is it important to
the people that you work with and to the
people that you were forward so that's a
very broad definition grand strategy is
often associated with in some way or
another military affairs military
history there is a reason for that
because if you think of grand strategy
as the calculated relationship of Em's
of means two large cans if you think
about it as the question of how do you
get from where you are to where you want
to go if you think about it in terms of
organizing large operations large
systems complex networks the kinds of
things that you have to worry about in
your own country and then if you think
about where would you go to find
textbooks on that subject where would
you go to find principles for how to do
that where would you go to pull together
much of the best that has been written
and but about this subject not just for
the last 25 years but perhaps for the
last twenty five hundred years you might
well go to the great classical works of
grand strategy Alec's times for example
within the Chinese tradition or
facilities
the Peloponnesian War our closets or met
or Nick for example and it's not that we
are interested in these texts because
they teach you how to fight wars it's
because the exercise of fighting wars is
one of the oldest of human activities
and it may well be the oldest the oldest
organized human activity so people and
states have spent more time over more
centuries thinking about that in the
context of war than in any other context
that has come down to us by way of
written texts that does not mean however
that the study of grand strategy today
or even that the study of grand strategy
then was always a deep red for fighting
wars so if you read a text like
facilities on the Peloponnesian wars as
we do as one of the introductory texts
in our class you find it is not only a
commentary on this great war between the
Athenians and the Spartans 2,500 years
ago what you find that is it it is a
profound commentary on human nature it
is a profound commentary on the way in
which they organized themselves the
weight which go in which states destroy
themselves and it is still read
fruitfully for those purposes despite
the fact that the military technology
discussed in that ancient text is now
profoundly out of date hardly anybody
employs hoplites anymore or triremes
anymore to engage in military affairs
that ladies and gentlemen is what we in
the grand strategy class called transfer
ability to take principles extracted
from one different time and place and
culture and see if they are transferable
and that really is how we like to think
about grand strategy general we like to
think about principles that cross time
and
base and cultures we like to think about
principles that are timeless in the
sense that they have been around for a
long time and are not bound by any
particular place or period but at the
same time principles that are time lean
in the sense that they are giving up
used to us or they can be of use to us
today so timeless but time we is I think
the definition of a classical work
that's why we read the classes in first
place whether it's literature or whether
it's poetry or whether it is the
classics of grand strategy and from that
we believe certain principles can be
extracted but actually are useful in
this time which like all other times has
a host of problems confronting but one
of those problems we find in a
university say is the problem of how do
we think that's not a new problem i'm
sure people have had a problem of how to
think through out as long as people have
been thinking but at the moment there is
a division and the academic community
into a considerable extent i think it
spills over into professional
communities like you on how we think one
whole one extreme one end of this
spectrum is what we might call anecdotal
ism that is just telling stories just
accumulating cases if you are a doctor
telling your own experiences but not
putting them into any kind of order just
a kind of bare chronology or a mindless
recounting of what has happened with no
attempt to draw lessons from that you've
all read history books that do this
you've all read boring history books
where it's just one battle after another
it's one state collapse after another
it's one failed politician after another
but no lessons are extracted from it
you're left either to extract the
lessons yourself or put them book down
because you find it so boring and
useless so that's one end of this
intellectual spectrum anecdotal ISM but
there is another end to this
intellectual spectrum that is
particularly evident these days in the
modern social sciences here but also
elsewhere in this country and around the
rope and this is the preoccupation with
theory somehow the advent of computer or
technology somehow the advent of the
capability to crunch numbers much faster
and much more effectively than was
possible in the past has led to the
illusion that everything can be reduced
to numbers that systems complex systems
can be rendered in simple terms or if
not in simple terms then in complex
terms made simple by computers and then
through the accumulation of all of this
statistical data and through the
accumulation of the patterns that derive
from it as they are explained to us by
the computers we can extract wisdom now
you've all seen and evolve had
experience with theoretical models that
do not connect with reality that's one
of the great tasks that anybody who's
involved in practical affairs has got to
think of is how you connect theory with
reality and I think increasingly it does
not connect increasingly there is too
big a gap between reality and theory and
that's the other end of this
intellectual spectrum that I mentioned
to you it's the flip side it's the polar
opposite of the moonless my a
meaningless mindless and a total ism
that's over here and the tendency to
reduce all of reality to a set of
computer driven models which
is over here I think grand strategy is
somewhere in between at least that's
where we try to push and I'd like to
illustrate this by simply mentioning
several fundamental principles of grand
strategy as we teach them to our
students and our students range from
sophomores up through postdoctoral
fellows had a diverse range of students
but this is what Betsy has been hearing
as she has come into our seminar over
the last year and half or so she's been
very serious about this these are just a
few examples offenses that are perfectly
obvious when stated but they have to be
stated in order to become obvious it's a
paradise here's one recognize that ends
our infant but means are never infant
hence the need to be precise about
objectives if you're talking about
objectives you can formulate objectives
right and left until you turn blue there
can be an infinite number of objectives
you can make your objective pie in the
sky as we say in the states are many
times in the sky but all of this has to
be tethered to a certain reality about
means this is exactly what Betsy was
saying about 15 minutes ago stand up
here it's all very nice for University
be sponsoring this conference but even
Yale University has got to think about
the constraints that means impose on
ends and so that's perfectly basic
things cost something and yet how often
do we see people spinning off objectives
without reference to costs or to means
it's the discipline of linking those two
things that I think is inherent in grand
strategy and if you go back to the most
ancient texts which may well have to do
with the movement of armies across
landscapes you will see the same thing
because facilities some zoo Pericles
Alcibiades etc these people face back
saying problem then so it's timeless but
at the same time it's time another one
is to recognize that ends and means are
related to one another you cannot
compartmentalize them they have an
interconnected relationship if you pick
two ambitious and end it can over
stretch your means and we all can think
of examples of this think of the British
Empire in its last days when it was
greatly overstretched thereby giving
rise to Professor Kennedy's most famous
term from his book the rise and fall of
the great powers Imperial overstretch
think of the United States and its
periodic problem with over stretching
its commitment so if you do this you can
weaken yourself if you project means too
ambitious that you can weaken yourself
by protect ends to ambitiously you can
week under sub by overstretching means
but you can also corrupt ms by taking
inappropriate means let's say you have
some objective in mind but let's say it
means by which you seek to pursue that
objective are so offensive or immoral or
draconian or whatever it might be it
actually it actually corrupts what
you're trying to think of the Bush
administration's torture memos for
example and think of the damage that
that did in proportion to what it
actually achieved it's going to be a
textbook case in the importance of not
letting the means you choose corrupt the
ends that you have in mind the third
principle would be too
recognize that perfection is never
possible we've all been told this in
religion Christianity has a concept of
original sin for example which is making
that point fairly firming but it's also
a grand strategic in principle
perfection would be trying to do
everything perfectly and of course you
exhaust yourself you exhaust others I
trying to do that perfection it's often
been said as the enemy of the good and
the good is when we are all seeking but
the good is contention the good is going
to be inferred the good is going to
leave something left undone active other
had a wonderful sentence in the prince
in which he says God does not wish to do
everything God leaves a few things to
use a unique I leaves some things for us
to do so recognizing the limits of
perfection recognizing the importance of
doing the best you can but understanding
at the same time but they're always
going to be problems with the approach
that you take is I think an important
element of grand strategy I have studied
professional interpreting book on the
strategy of containment as articulated
and implemented by the United States
during the Cold War period but one of
the very periodic problems of
containment was exactly what was it that
we were trying to contain if we went out
and try to contain one thing like the
Soviet Union then there would be
concerns about all kinds of other things
that were developing as in the early
period for example the People's Republic
of China or later on hoochie men or
later on uranium bullets it was always
somebody out there who was doing
something that caused a focus on just
the Soviet Union to seem dangerous
somehow so okay there were other
American strategists who shifted around
and said
we're going to deal with all of those
threats out there we're going to cover
the waterfront in dealing with these
dangers and of course what they ran into
was exhaustion financial exhaustion
physical exhaustion political exhaustion
in terms of exhausting the domestic
political tolerance of strategies like
those that we were following for example
in the Vietnam War and so containment
was an oscillation over 45 years between
these two principles I think it would
have been better if it could have been
recognized early on that you cannot have
all of that strategy and you cannot have
all of this strategy because there are
problems anytime you do that but its
strategy is kind of a tight wire act
it's kind of a trapeze act strategy is a
matter of balancing things there are
never solutions this way or the other
way it's the tension between the two and
it's the balance that you maintain like
walking a tightrope with a balancing of
hope that comes much closer to what
random strategy actually is another
principle is recognized that friction
will happen or to put it another way
what can go wrong will go wrong this is
a universal principle I know that it
does not have to be explained to you all
of us confront it in life but it's
amazing how frequently in planning we
fail to take it into account and this is
where the study of disasters in brand
strategy actually can be very productive
as case studies friction is always going
to be there and because it is going to
be there there's one other brand
strategic principle that we teach which
is the value of seeking leverage if your
means are limited if friction is going
to be a problem always
it becomes very important to look for
those points of leverage at which you
can apply a small amount of energy or a
relatively small amount of energy and
produce disproportionate effects produce
big effects and that's getting very
close to the center of what brand
strategy is some all about looking for
points of leverage at which you can have
the maximum results with the minimum
investment of everyone there are many
examples of this in history although
actually fewer examples than failures to
do this but one of the most famous
examples from my field of American
diplomatic history in the cold war with
General George Marshalls famous speech
at Harvard University in june nineteen
forty-seven announcing the marshall plan
this was a period when it was great fear
that the soviet union was either going
to take over europe militarily or more
likely that the Europeans themselves out
of despair would vote in communists who
would then take orders from the Soviet
units only two years after the world and
yet with a single well calculated though
not well delivered speech Marshall
promised American assistance promises
something revolutionary the idea that
this country previously throughout its
history in peacetime always isolationist
would now become international and would
develop a sense of responsibility for
the health of other societies and simply
the making of that one speech turn the
whole momentum at least in terms of the
cold war in Europe from around that's
the most famous example of leverage in I
think the history of grand strategy and
that is why even today you constantly
hear people say whenever some problem
comes up whether the problem is
inadequate resources here or the problem
is
mismanagement over here or whether the
problem is poverty here or illness here
or whatever everybody's first reaction
is we need a Marshall Plan 4x whatever X
is well you can't have a Marshall Plan
for everything but you could think about
Marshall and you can think about his own
plan and you can think about how it
worked and you could think about the
tricks that he was using at that point
and it could be something to aspire to
not necessarily something that you can
achieve but something to aspire to so
one of the things you guys are going to
be doing in this this week is doing
policy briefs you're going to be
organized into teams you'll be
presenting briefs on your own particular
problems we do the same thing in our
class and in honor of general Marshall
we call these Marshall briefs because we
see him as an exemplar of this strategy
of seeking leverage finally one other
point relating to grand strategy and
this is think of it as an ecological
discipline think of it as a discipline
in which everything is related to
everything else you may well think and
certainly many universities train you to
think in compartmentalized terms
universities are even organized in
compartmentalised terms they are called
departments department of history
department of a political science
department of economics i think there is
too little effort within universities to
think about pulling these things
together producing students who are able
to cross these disciplines to think
about how they interconnect with one
another to think about the world as a
whole and that is
a huge problem today we understand the
need to do this clearly enough when
we're talking about the global ecology
we're talking about something like
global warming we can see these
interconnections operating we can
document that we can calculate but how
many people thought ecologically in the
run-up to the financial bust of last
year how many people who were in charge
of this country's economy and several
other countries economies were thinking
ecologically when they mindlessly put
zillions of dollars into subprime
mortgages had they thought about why
mortgages of that kind of are called
subprime in the first place had they
thought about the history of proven
previous financial booms and busts going
all the way back to the touch boom the
Dutch tulip crisis of 1637 had they
thought about human nature and the
tendency of human beings to overstretch
the tendency of speculators to let hope
run away from reality and they thought
in these terms no they were simply
operating on the basis of complicated
mathematical models that even those guys
did not understand they have become so
complicated that's an example of
parochial thinking that is not an
example of ecological thinking and
that's what we are trying to avoid in
our place so timeless but timely that's
what grand strategy is I would just
complete with this question where have
you heard this kind of thing before
where have you heard things like well
you shouldn't do too much of this but
you shouldn't do too much of that yeah
where have you heard this thing about
happen you really have to kind of
balance these things where have you
heard this stuff about you have to
soon to us but we can't exactly exactly
can you want to do when you grow up
where have you heard that before okay
parents right teachers right coaches
particularly think about what a coach
does in any realm of athletics the coach
trains a young person by exposing them
to the lore and the history and the
rules of the game and then by practice
incessant practice so if they go out and
play the game and build stamina and
build a mount and part of that knowledge
in any game is the ability to see all of
the playing field at once in other words
an ecological perspective if you're just
looking at your foot you're not going to
be a very good football player okay and
then what does it coach do when the game
starts the coach said the coach says kid
you're on your own you have to go out
and play this game I cannot speak into
some ear phone and tell you where to put
your foot at every stage you have to
have an instinct for this yourself you
don't consult some complicated computer
model you don't listen to old grizzled
football players telling you how it was
back in nineteen forty two or whatever
you have to go out and do it yourself
and that's the bottom line on grand
strategy that's what you are going to
have to face that's what our students
are going to have to face and that is
the connection just one other thought
that I would like to leave you with
where does medicine fit in to all of
this what is medicine anyway at one
level it is certainly the accumulation
of wisdom over a period of time that
goes back about as far as we take grand
strategy the Hippocratic oath and what
lies behind that is
comes from the same period really where
we start the study of the grand strategy
class the accumulated wisdom of how to
treat illness but at the same time the
modification of that wisdom in the light
of new technologies that have come along
the training that a young doctor or a
health care professional gets it seems
to me reflects or is very similar to
what I'm talking about here because it
would be important for you to have a
sense of that accumulated body of wisdom
out there it certainly would be
important for you to have a sense of the
latest trends in research and treatment
that are going on out there all of those
things are critically important but it
all comes down to the individual patient
and when you're looking at the
individual patient what are you looking
at you're looking at the history of that
person not an entire class not an entire
country looking at the history of that
person and you're looking at that person
as a whole not just the lungs and not
just the spleen and not just the brain
but if you're a good doctor and even if
you're a specialist you are thinking
about the relationship of your specialty
to that person as a whole you're doing
case histories you're connecting the
individual in the particular with the
general and the theoretical and that
ladies and gentlemen really is what
brand strategy is all about as we think
about it here thank you so much well
good morning ladies and gentlemen as
Professor goddess yesterday afternoon
was sitting in his study composing that
eloquent address I was working in my
backyard pruning my roses and attacking
the weeds the garden has now inflicted
its return damage on me and I woke up
this morning with a very very stiff
right rump and present I can't really
tell
it's more painful to stand and to sit we
shall see I beg your forgiveness if I
move to sit but I think I can get this
to stand yeah but there could be an
excess of medical advice which is
another grand strategic principle we we
try to inculcate so you've heard from
Professor gatos about the principles of
grand strategy that we try to carry out
in our year-long course with
undergraduates but also with graduate
professional students and you've heard
that we start off chiefly with texts
from military encounters because they
are there where the original writings on
grand strategy came from to think of the
war as a whole or the campaign as a
whole or even the fighting a war to make
sure that the peace which follows is a
piece that you would want and others
would want to so we begin you know
unashamedly with the military dimension
of human activity which has been a long
and very sordid one but it's given us
lessons and we also try to think and
teach the students to think about
different levels of operation in the
pursuit of a strategy if the grand
strategy is for example what is
formulated by the big people at the top
this is a photograph well known
photograph to our students at least of
Winston Churchill and President Franklin
Roosevelt meeting with their Chiefs of
Staff their leading Air Force Navy and
military officers at the conference at
Casablanca in January 1943 where they
decide they formulated the grants
energy for the rest of the war that they
would have to do that Germany was the
prime enemy it was just too big too
powerful technologically Germany first
though there would be of course
campaigning in the Pacific the
unconditional surrender this would be a
war to the end there's going to be no
negotiated peace then you had to get
things done and this is where the grand
strategist turned to the people who have
to get things done the Chiefs of Staff
go home with a set of operating
instructions you have to win the battle
of the atlantic you have to get command
of the air over Germany you have to
figure out how to land on a hostile
Shore go and do it it's rather like a
CEO a new CEO coming into PepsiCo or
whatever and saying here's a new set of
operating procedures here is a set of
things we want to expand in the Latin
American market we want to bring in new
products now you go and fix it so we are
interested not just in those timeless
principles but way interested through
the case studies we look at at how
things get done or how things fail to
get done and so we come down from the
grand strategic level two more to the
operational level so staying just for
one more minute only at the military
level here in nineteen forty-three years
Churchill and Roosevelt flew back home
the Western Allies were losing the
Battle of the Atlantic they were losing
too many merchant ships to the German
u-boats and yet somewhere in the course
of 1943 a number of people figured out
how better to fight the u-boats how to
run the convoys more effectively how to
put more fuel into long-range aircraft
like this Liberator so you could cover
the gap in the Atlantic above air
coverage how to bring you a weapon some
of them invented by very eccentric
people how to bring all of these to play
there had to be an organization under
the big guys it's no use the Minister of
Health saying we want to do this he's
the cabinet saying we want to do this if
it isn't organization and what I'm going
to talk about for the rest of my remarks
is a case study which is not at all a
military one it takes me back rather
fondly to my years in the northeast of
England where I was taught social and
economic history of the Industrial
Revolution in England and it was a
social history it was a social history
of a country which was beginning to
become modern a social history of a
country where millions of people were
coming from the countryside into the
shanty cities and towns especially in
the north of England it was one where
the poor were much more visible because
there was many more of them between the
Year 1800 1900 in other words in the
19th century the population of Great
Britain goes up fourfold from 10 million
to 40 million people you have a
population explosion it's the one which
is so worried Reverend Thomas Malthus
when he wrote about the other challenge
of a population explosion how are you to
deal with it this was called
increasingly because one could see that
industrialization was bringing more and
more people into these gigantic cities
slums cities how are you deal with it
this was the so-called condition of
England question and it therefore is a
sort of 4runner or pre data of some of
the challenges facing health and
administrative officials in some of the
gigantic cities of today of subpar
of mexico city of of accra how do you do
it where you get started how are you
going to handle this thing and it became
a pressing matter of debate among among
the upper classes and among the middle
classes now among those who are starting
to think professionally about health
care about improvement about
modernization and essentially how how
one was going to move away from this
truly awful Dickensian world or poverty
in the slums how are you going to do it
how are you going to improve housing how
are you going to where were you going to
think strategically about how did you
get things done and what's more how are
you going and this was an underlying
concern how are you going to avoid the
discontent swelling up in these enormous
city slums being exploited by those who
wanted to have a really transformative
political revolution not necessarily a
social revolution this is one of the
most famous works of the time I've used
the original german title and
frontispiece here dalaga der arbeit
natasa in England written by angles who
later on became Marx's best friend and
partner marks until this time had been
thinking chiefly in terms of Oh
idealistic philosophy post Hegelian
philosophy how do you explain change in
history what is real and what is not
real and then when he reads angles the
condition of a working class in England
he suddenly terms from being an idea
idealistic philosopher regalian to
thinking about the real world a material
world what he calls the the sub
structure
the foundations and begins to flip Hagel
around and to argue it's the foundations
of material social foundations the
relations of production who holds a
cache who owns the factories where are
the workers positions where their rights
and so you get this if you like almost
competition throughout 19th century
Europe and then spreading to the u.s. a
competition between those who thought
that it could be nothing more than
radical reform and a total
transformation of society getting rid of
a ruling class getting rid of a
bourgeoisie and others who thought that
there was a way to go which would
improve the lot of the working classes
which would which would be a solution in
any case and among these as a leading
contender although he never would have
thought of himself as a leading
contender against marked there is they
are the writings and the thoughts of
this chopper Jeremy Bentham was also a
philosopher of the early 19th century he
invents or puts forward the whole notion
a whole doctrine of utilitarianism he's
interested in usefulness and practical
pneus in how you get things done he
defined happiness for society happiness
was the greatest good of the greatest
number and effort could not happiness
could not just exist in a society for
the ruling class or the aristocratic
elite he wasn't so much thinking over
any fear of a communist revolution as
some later thinkers and politicians were
it was how do you achieve the greatest
good for the greatest number he was
suffused with that optimism which came
out of the age of the Enlightenment he
believed in the perfectibility of human
beings he was not in favor of notions of
medieval notions if you like or pre
modern notion
that man was just born with original sin
I his key word and you see it and a lot
of his writing to see it in a lot of a
legislation which we call benzamide
legislation or utilitarian legislation
the favorite word was the improvement he
what he was looking for was the
improvement of humankind so he had this
belief that you could by using your
brains and by using certain mechanisms
and structures you could improve things
that condition of a working class which
had been so bleakley described by angles
which cause marks to forecasted over
time they'll be ever greater
impoverishment of the proletariat so
there would be in Marxist view an
inevitable proletarian revolution
Bentham did not accept it or you could
do things you know you needed structures
but you start with an idea you start
with an ideology you start with a belief
in the improve ability of the human
condition so essentially optimistic a
lot of utilitarian writing is
excessively optimistic a lot of it is
does not assume all of the things we try
to teach some grand strategy about
frictions about things going wrong but
this is this is pushing for improvement
it's kind of interesting when you think
about it ladies and gentlemen because
this age of the first third or first 40
years or so of the 19th centuries when
we recognize a whole set of them of
reforms as they were call this was the
age of reform this was the age of the
abolition of the slave trade in the
British Empire this was the age of the
abolition of not just of the slave trade
but of slavery itself this was the age
of the emancipation of Catholics who
will no longer after 18
9 forbidden to practice their faith this
is the age of the getting rid of
protectionism getting rid of the Corn
Laws this is the age in which you begin
to think of all other measures you
abolish flogging in the Army you abolish
as a form of capital punishment you
abolish cruel and inhumane capital
punishments no more people going to be
your publicly carotid in the street or
something like that so the Reformers are
everywhere but you're now not talking
just about abolishing things you're
talking about improving things and you
need you need you you start off with the
ideas of improvement you start off with
a book like this on the principles of
morals and legislation but look at that
second word legislation you don't
believe you're going to do a just by
preaching from the pulpit although there
was an awful lot of pulpit preaching in
early Victorian Britain you're going to
do it by the state by legislation and so
what you get in addition to of these
various acts for the abolition of the
slave trade or the emancipation of a
Catholics or you begin to get from this
period onwards again look at a date are
things called the factory acts it's far
too detailed for me even to interpret it
here but what they were what acts first
of all to make it illegal for the
employment of children to work in the
mines down in the mines at the first of
the factory and mines act then it was
restricting the amount of hours that
could be worked so that the working
classes were not working 12 14 hours a
day there's restricted number of hours
in the week there were safer T
legislation improvement in conditions in
the mines and the textile mills has
improved improved improvements in
compensation
there were arguments about heated
arguments of course and sometimes many
of them lost by the utilitarians because
they were proposing too much perhaps too
fast and the question is who was going
to do this even if you passed the act
you needed to do something to enforce it
to patrol it to ensure her to report on
it it was all very well for certain
enlightened factory owners like Owen up
in New lanik new lanark is just outside
Edinburgh and Scotland's so very well
for him to turn his factory into what
was called a new model factory and to
make it a place with good housing with
schools attendant to the factory or next
to the factory for children for improved
health conditions etc very paternalistic
the Owens new or lanik system but it he
was arguing it would be the factory
owners themselves which who did it but
of course he was in a very very small
minority of factory owners who found
that they wanted to invest money they
wanted to invest resources in this set
of improvements even when Owen
experimented by reducing the work day
and the work week and found that he got
greater worker productivity and output
if your worker was not in the factory
next to the machine for 14 hours a day
but was having an 8-hour day the overall
output went up even with the sort of
rational utilitarian Bentham aight
discoveries and arguments many people
resisted it so there had to be other
ways of getting this done had other
things other things were also necessary
you needed to improve if you were if you
weren't a society which was growing so
fast which was so turbulent which was so
frightening you needed something more in
terms of provision of structures of
security and safety in the great cities
than simply calling in the Redcoats
calling in the British Army you had to
it you had to have in addition to your
social improvements you needed
structures for for the security of the
fabric of the society so it's not
surprising that it can look at the date
here not surprised what I can put a date
on I beg upon but it's not surprising
that in 1840 the English Parliament
passes an act of legislation for the
creation of the Metropolitan Police
Force this is a first civil police force
in history it isn't armed and in fact
the British police were not armed until
about 25 years ago it was paid it was
professional it was recruited it took
the army out of society took the army
out of politics became the model for
police forces and cities across the
world and it was providing security but
was providing a dinner in a kind of
support of constructive way you took
away the image that the authorities were
always repressing you or suppressing you
police board's civilian police board
approved the appointment of the logo
inspector or Commissioner training was
insisted upon so you're putting together
a package of improvements some of which
were more to do with negative Liberty
some more to do with positive Liberty um
let's go on
I said who carries without this must be
it you know incredible challenge to any
society which is developing fast is
encountering massive social fabric
problems health care problems
supervision supervision administration
problems just trying to get things done
I've been emphasizing throughout my talk
this is at least as my particular
interest my particular cut in grand
strategy is who does it and how do they
experiment how do they figure things out
this is another apparently obscure act
it is an act of parliament of 1857 which
went through both houses has got a
double-barreled name Lord North good and
Trevelyan in the House of Commons and
what it did was to essentially establish
a world's first permanent professional
civil service you can see that it is a
report so you get through this bet is
very familiar with this you start up
with a working party or committee it
investigates a problem it produces a
report the report gets discussed it
might be amended it then goes to a
further body John goddess nice it on far
too many University committees where we
get reports on the improvement of the
syllabus of you know yale college or
something like that and in this case it
goes through the parliament and gets
enacted what did it do it got rid of the
old corruption it got rid of baksheesh
it got rid of bribes because it
established a permanent professional
civil service where you could only enter
after examinations you had to take
national competitive examinations to
enter you had a fixed salary scale and
it was in ladder rung ladder ways or
seniority counted you are no longer
permitted to take any sorts of fees
yourself customs officials who took
customs fees
clarks of court who took court fees and
put off of them in their back pocket it
was to be the end of that it was to
create a professional national
administrative cadre which would get
things done and the training of the the
examination but also the training in the
first few years of the civil service was
to say was to with the conviction that
you could you could take these
administrative skills a transfer ability
that John Garrett was talking about you
take a transfer ability because you'd
been taught like what's a problem what's
the contending theories what's the
evidence where do we get the data from
this is pure Bentham isms being driven
by what's the problem how can it be
solved how do we measure it how do we
report on it the whole notion of modern
bureaucracies spewing out vast thousands
and thousands of reports and paperwork
probably goes back to the North cut
rebellion reforms and the notion that
this is this is a way to do it in
Benson's view it was scientific it it
was really supposed to work did it well
not that easily I said that Bentham and
the utilitarians had this great optimism
they found it for all your advances they
made the population was increasing the
areas of slum development were
increasing the they suddenly they
discovered over time the issue of
poverty not just in the inner cities
which was right in their face but rural
poverty poverty in the countryside you
needed to have another commission on
that you needed to investigate what were
the special problems of the countryside
in the age of the agricultural
depression after 1873 in
nine eighteen ninety nine to nineteen
hundred Britain gets itself involved in
South Africa and the second Boer War
there's an appeal for volunteers to come
and join the British Army in Manchester
remember Manchester of of angles a
condition of the working class and
Manchester in Manchester out of the
12,000 young men who apply to join the
British Army to go fight seven thousand
are turned down because of inadequate
weight and height and this is a massive
shock of further shock to the system its
statistical evidence and the more you do
it the more you have reports from
Roundtree and Booth who's Roundtree
studies a condition of the poorer
classes and poverty in the Town of York
and the City of York and Yorkshire
you're getting evidence that these are
hard problems they don't easily go away
you're getting some examples of success
and you're looking for other models of
success is this is what's happening in
you know some of the sudden English
cities transferable to the larger cities
in the north can we learn from the
Germans social legislation under
Bismarck should there be what do we
learn from german social legislation
about creating pensions about having
health insurance for the first time what
do we learn in other words they're still
benzamide they're still questioning are
still going about things but if you read
if you'd ever read it say a couple of
the writings of the english novelist of
the into warriors George Orwell if you
read his down and out in london and
paris or you read in particular book of
his called a novel of his a sort of
novel but descriptions the road to Wigan
Pier all goes and lives with the poor he
goes to
poor houses to working houses to
workshops he goes hop picking an old
Etonian from the highest class he wants
to understand what's happening and he
details it is still a way to go so I
don't want to end with any sense at all
that just because you have a grand
strategy up there just because you've
got mr. bentham with his principles of
morals and legislation just because you
have a northcote rebellion reforms you
get it done you you get you achieve what
you're going to so I'm going to end with
one cartoon which comes from 1943-44
when the British government aware that
in a few years time at least they would
win the second world war that they were
going to get out of it was began even in
war time to think of how do we deal with
the challenges facing our society how do
we finally get to if we can put all of
his energy into defeating Hitler how can
we not use some of that energy after the
war to defeat poverty to defeat all of
it all the things we've seen be getting
in the way so the Beveridge report is
yet another example of Bentham aight
action which is you you investigate the
state of the British nation you
investigate the social fabric you you
note how few of the children are getting
anywhere beyond the age of 12 or 13 in
their schooling and you report are not
in the hope that you're going to create
a better society and you bring it to the
Parliament and you get after 1945 with
the coming in of clement attlee labour
administration you get the beginning so
what's so-called welfare state the
creation of a pension system the
creation of national health insurance
the
regulations over the hospitals and the
medication you get improvements in the
schools you get the opening up of the
ancient universities to ever more
members of les advantage classes you
could still go to parts of England
Scotland Europe and this country today
and see that there was still a long long
list of things to be done but what I'm
interested in what I leave you with
ladies and gentlemen is the thought that
yes you can have your five days here at
Yale and yes you have in many cases long
studied these problems and challenges of
Health Administration health care and
yes you're much more aware much better
than us of that what the priority of the
challenges are but I think that you
while one they start at the top even an
identifying what is the number one
priority for your country's health care
problems the questions are how do we get
it done and who's going to do it and how
do we report on it and how do we get
feedback and how do we learn and can we
get a way of having people understand
that you are like the Bentham is kind of
pushing a boulder along and it's a very
heavy voter and sometimes it gets stuck
in the mud and then you have to think of
ways of releasing it of pushing that
boulder on and that's what professionals
are for that's what the middle managers
are for thats what the people who see
the problem because they're right down
there trying to implement solutions
that's what your job is thank you very
much ladies and gentlemen